viele glauben das sind ganze ein
bisschen tanzen im wasser ist aber es
ist eigentlich das hat gar nichts mit
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport bot dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast im sportbad
unseres synchronschwimmerinnen frau
korporal anna maria alexandra und frau
karin i alexander herzlich willkommen
ihr seid so erfrischt aus tokio zurück
oder zwei olympische spiele eine top
platzierung für österreich erzählt
einmal wie waren eure eindrücke in japan
ja es war wirklich super ja das ganze
gefühl zum zweiten mal eigentlich ja es
war ja eigentlich ja was hat euch denn
alles so beeindruckt ja das olympische
dorf weil man sieht dort sehr viele
sportler aus für ihn in verschiedenen
sportarten basketball
halle war gross unglaublich
gemeinsam dieses viele egal was man
ja
das gefühl eigentlich trotz dollar wenn
man realisiert dass es einst will dass
es ihr dass intel das gras es ist ja es
ist der welt
fünf jahre wegen dollar gepreist und ja
wahnsinnig erfolgreich
ich habe es den siebten platz mit
91,8
aber wir werden uns dann auch gleich
erklären was das alles bedeutet für alle
die nicht so synchronschwimmen experten
und expertinnen sind es auf jeden fall
die beste österreichische platzierung
bei olympischen spielen geschafft was
bedeutet euch so ein erfolg mit dieser
leistung bei den olympischen spielen ja
das war eigentlich das ziel von uns dass
wir die bestmögliche platzierung
eigentlich die beste plätze
begonnen gewinne ja das haben wir
geschafft und
dort acht nationen der welt zu kommen
das haben wir auch gesagt ja natürlich
wäre es ein traum gewesen dass wir unter
die top sechs kommen warum hat gewusst
dass wir das gewonnen aber das hat ein
bisschen gefällt so von der welt her ja
und auch das feedback war sehr sehr gut
man ahlen egal von loebs landsmann der
ersten training das seit uns wirklich
sehr weit sie ist extra zu uns gekommen
und hat uns gratuliert und sie wir sind
auch eigentlich nicht was wir noch
machen muss und damit wir das bekommen
was wir verdienen aber ja ich sicher
dass noch mehr
sicher vor egal welchen tagen das ist
der fünfte platz aber ja sicher wieder
um zufrieden sind wir nicht aber wir
wissen dass wir das ist noch mehr ja und
das ist auch das ziel da für die
nächsten jahre jetzt hat sie gesagt ein
bisschen hat dann noch gefehlt wie kann
man sich das vorstellen wenn ihr dort
schwimmt ja und er sitzt dann die punkte
und ihr wisst sondern kommt das super
feedback woher könnte dann wissen was
denn noch fehlen würde oder was wir noch
machen müsst damit daneben ein top 6
platz zum beispiel rausschaut beiden
politiker es hier ist eigentlich mit der
leistung sondern man kann sich ja ich
meine im vergleich zu kanada der italien
weil wir wissen wir waren besser aber
natürlich einfach nicht zehnmal besser
zu sein oder zwanzigmal so nach
hunderttausend mal das war's egal ja die
tränen als land gesagt vor drei jahren
wir werden jetzt versuchen dass wir die
wertungsrichter noch einmal überzeugen
und eigentlich das heißt einmal 91,8 bei
so einem großen ereignis ist ja so sehr
gut
bei den verhalten gegen haben genau
welten die analyse ja gesehen dass sie
eine wertungsrichterin aus den
niederlanden die drittbeste werden uns
gegangen gerade das waren 95 das war in
china hat 96 begonnen russland 9,98 und
das eigentlich war ja
es war bei den olympischen spielen das
ist auch eine sehr große chance jahren
sind wahrlich wenn einer das sieht dann
vielleicht sein dass auch andere beim
nächsten
das heißt die hoffnung ist da dass auch
die anderen neuer potenzial erkennen und
dann eben solche top bewertung noten
geben also in zukunft auf jeden fall
noch luft nach oben obwohl er schon so
gut unterwegs war jetzt ist die sport
hat eine sehr subjektive sport und man
weiß auch in der vergangenheit dass sie
immer wieder nach großereignissen wo ihr
nicht zufrieden war
mit den punkten und den wertungen dass
sie das auch gesagt habt also das sind
nicht ruhig geblieben sondern auch
gesagt hatte wir finden das war nicht
fair bewertet da hätten wir uns mehr
punkte verdient gehabt ist das nicht
auch gefährlich in ordnung sport wenn
man da wirklich auch offen ist oder
warum entscheidet ihr euch dann dass er
das so sagt viele haben uns gesagt so
gut ab dass ihr das gemacht
was zu sagen wie wir ja war ja man hat
immer angst dass beim nächsten wettkampf
das klima
so sagt ja dass und das gleich für die
sportart ist obwohl es eigentlich das
gegenteil ist das wenn es so weitergeht
dann ist das leicht für die sportart
regal bei der gfk hat uns seine tränen
gefragt ob wir nach der weltmeister 2009
10 waren wir eigentlich sehr sehr
enttäuscht auch nach der
europameisterschaft 2008 sein und wir
haben nun sage ich hoffentlich
geäußert und sie hat uns gefragt ob wir
eine strafe bekommen kann von fina vom
weltverband weil wir online eigentlich
unsere gefühle und über sind gleich
meine weil das feld das ist
leitungssystem gerettet haben
keine strafe bekommen dass ich bestraft
worden aber jetzt da wir haben eine
unser verband hat eine e-mail bekommen
weil wir das gemacht haben das finde ich
einfach ja das finde ich nicht hin weil
das bauwerk ist eine gefühle äußern und
jetzt allen sportarten ist ja also genau
das war die antwort von uns im verband
also habt ihr in dem sie den mut
bewiesen und gezeigt
wenn euch das am herzen liegt und wenn
er da sagen wollt dann tatsächlich auch
und dann sagt sie das auf jeden fall
geht es da einen anderen weg und sieht
man auch in eurer sportlichen
vorbereitung in eurer leistung ich
trainiere in der südstadt neben euch
seit vielen vielen jahren dass dich
braucht ihr euch
schon seit vielen jahren und es ist
unglaublich was ihr alles trainiert also
man sieht ja dass ein chronischer man im
wettkampf vielleicht gar nicht was
dahinter steckt was dein training alles
zu tun ist kann sie uns vielleicht für
alle die eben keine expertinnen und
experten sind schon ein bisschen
erklären wie das sind training abläuft
damit man solche leistungen bei den
großereignissen schaffen kann ja
eigentlich viele glauben das
synchronschwimmen ein bisschen tanzen im
wasser ist aber es ist eigentlich das
hat gar nichts mit der bavaria machen
das eigentlich so dass es leicht
haushalt weil das sagt der beratung
und eigentlich brauchen wir fast alles
was
ja das board oder zum beispiel braucht
wir brauchen das was das thema brauchen
wir gleichen das was ein sprinter
beweglich beweglichkeit ja schnell
greift die luft anhalten
das was die mädchen im ballett brauchen
die strecken in den beinen schöne beine
die qualität der bewegung ins haus sehr
wichtig die elemente aus drucktechnik
also viele elemente die wir herrschen
mist ich habe nämlich dass ich im
endeffekt immer in der früh komme ist
schon da ist schon längst im wasser und
wenn ich fertig bin seid immer noch
immer sind ich bin mir da nicht wenig
vormittags stunden lang im wasser und am
nachmittag wenn ich zum training kommen
dass jetzt wieder da was also auf wie
viele stunden kann man daher ungefähr
kommen mit dem ganzen training am tag
und dann auch die woche hochgerechnet
damit sich die leute ungefähr ein gefühl
davon machen können was das wirklich
bedeutet
das ganze jahr trainieren wir sehen
ja ja und vor dem wettkampf 7 bis 8
ja und das passiert weil wir eigentlich
fehlen den details arbeiten das muss im
kopf bleiben eine woche zum beispiel
ganz wenn ich irgendwie das ganze bild
key dann vergisst war eigentlich die
bewegung in die kleinen bei die leute
immer automatisiert jain und ja wenn man
das nicht wenn ja dann ist das leicht es
ist nichts so wie es ein bisschen mehr
benutzt rennen vor dem wettkampf machen
sie immer weniger bei jungs ist das
genau das gegenteil wenn manchmal obwohl
jetzt sind deutlich hatten wir diese
möglichkeiten als wahlfach
der organisation zufolge gegen zwei
stunden am tag und das war eigentlich
schon eine außergewöhnliche situation
für uns und
das ist jetzt viel mehr trainiert wenn
ihr
aber das war das selbst einmal das so
also da kann ich nur sagen wir genießen
das immer sehr wendig gut weil da immer
weniger trainieren eben um die erholung
zu fördern und nicht dass man nicht
trainieren möchte das bleibt trotzdem
intensiv aber statt sieben kilometer
sind es dann halt nur noch zwei oder
drei kilometer und dadurch kommt der
körper in die erholung druck gehabt
jetzt auch ein bisschen schon
angesprochen ihr habt sie auch den
vergleich tokio und rio de janeiro rio
de janeiro waren eure ersten spiele weil
es damals noch sehr jung gab es trotzdem
überrascht und eine top-platzierung
damals schon geschafft wie seht ihr den
kontrast zu 2016 und jetzt eben 2020 in
tokio
0 18 jahre alt wir haben nur zwei jahre
ausgleich vertreten ja bei großanlagen
sind ja und das werde ich auch das erste
jahr in der allgemeinen klasse das
bedeute eine sehr große rolle
damals wollten wir das finale und das
haben wir geschafft ja dieses jahr
wollten wir viel mehr beweisen sind die
sympathie garniert mit viel mehr
erfahrung
darf dann auch diese medaille hat uns
noch weiter motiviert und
selbstvertrauen gegeben und das war
ich glaube ich jetzt haben wir jetzt
fünf punkte mehr begonnen insgesamt das
technisch sind dass wir real insgesamt
ja es ist schon eine weile
bis 2019 haben wir im friedwald 87
punkte gemacht und das war ja wir
wollten immer schon seit vielen jahren
90 punkte bekommen aber wir haben nicht
gewusst was wir machen damit wir dass
wir gott und ich glaube gott hat uns ein
bisschen geholfen die wertung sich dann
eine pause gehört glaube ich sind
pflicht ja und das war auch für sie ein
hubert außen glaube ich ja und das ist
training haben uns gefragt wie ist es
auf einmal so dass ihr 92 das ist fast
92 das ist fünf punkte mehr als
weltmeister ab 2019 ja obwohl ich finde
das ist nicht so ein großer sprung war
dass ich meine dass 2009
also eigentlich sollte die
damals schon mehr
du hast jetzt die medaille schon
angesprochen die ihr euch auch
selbstvertrauen gegeben hat er hat es
bei der europameisterschaft zwei
bronzemedaillen gewonnen
vielleicht erklärt für uns noch mal kurz
die disziplinen in denen hier antritt
weil es ist ja doch sind komplizierter
da nicht gleichzeitig gibt der zwei
bewerbe und bei den olympischen spielen
ist dann doch wieder anders also erklärt
sich vielleicht einmal wie das genau
ausschaut bei euch ja bei allen
wettkämpfen eigentlich die europameister
von weltmeisterschaft haben wir das
technisat wird extra nicht bewertet aber
man bekommt eine medaille ist ein extra
würste mit zwei mal das technische gerät
vor dem finalen 2 man das früher
vollkommen finale und dann bekommt dann
für jede disziplin eine medaille bei den
olympischen spielen ist das team waren
zum beispiel am montag sind wir dass
friedrich gesammelt haben dienstag das
technische die wertungen von den zwei
disziplinen werden notiert der ersten
zwölf qualifizieren sich für das finale
und dann ist das viel geld und dann
nimmt man die punkte von friedrich am
mittwoch den punkt
am dienstag und man ahnt ihr diese zwei
punkte dahinter geben
auf jeden fall aber wo ist der
unterschied zwischen dem friedwald und
dem technischen gerät also was macht die
schwimmerisch anders was sind das zwei
komplett verschiedene choreographien
oder was ist da genau der unterschied
ist frei man kann alles machen es ist
nichts vorgegeben und bats ist wird man
hat vom parlamente die ja das land
ausführen muss eine bestimmte
reihenfolge
ja man muss das man bekommt eine extra
weil wir haben ja für diese fünf
elemente beim friedlichstes ausführung
atheistischen
und willigkeit und existiert diese
ausführung hat diesen gepresst und
fähigkeit ein in eine welt in exter die
elemente das heißt sie müssen zwei
verschiedene choreographien ja
trainieren und auch können und dann
abrufen binnen weniger tage auf höchstem
niveau na ja jetzt schon gehört dass
hier die sätze voneinander kompliziert
und beendet das liegt daran dass hier
schwestern seien aber die nicht nur
schwestern sondern drillings schwestern
gemeinsam mit ihrer schwester vassili
gibt und ihr seid jahr 2012 aus
griechenland nach österreich gekommen
erzählt uns vielleicht wie es dazu
gekommen ist dass ihr nach österreich
gekommen sei zum hier synchronschwimmen
professionell zu betreiben ja eigentlich
ja eigentlich hatten wir
ein paar probleme mit dem verwalter
verwarnt und ja wir hatten drei
möglichkeiten entweder im gegenlicht
land zu bleiben im nationalteam und
weiter zum beispiel so wie es war
die zweite möglichkeit vor 80 jahren in
glanz und weiter jahrhunderts auf die
schule konzentrieren und die dritte war
ja nach österreich kommen eigentlich die
zweite waren hier eine auswahl ja es
wäre
also wollte unbedingt ja
das war auf jeden fall die richtige zeit
sondern wahrscheinlich auch für euch
weil ja hier die rahmenbedingungen
habt uns natürlich auch froh dass ihr
beim bundesheer seitz und auch da das
bundesheer dementsprechend repräsentiert
aber wie ich schon gesagt habe seit eben
nicht nur zwei sondern ist zu dritt und
eure schwester war so wie wir sie alle
nennen mit dem spitznamen ist auch teil
des teams auch wenn sie dem druck nicht
stimmen kann welche rolle nimmt sie dann
in der ganzen konstellation in der
vorbereitung für euch ein ja eigentlich
sie denn die offizielle zeit statt mir
zum beispiel das bavaria streamen ja und
das ist schon einmal passiert in lyon
vor der qualifikation drei wollte ich
war krank und sie ist dann
genauso wie
genau auf dem niveau was ich eigentlich
andere stärke als
das erste
und ja sie hat alles was mich jetzt vor
den olympische spielen überall alles
mitgemacht sogar zwei aufgestanden weil
wir im vierten jahr hat sich hat bis zum
letzten moment alles gemacht so wie wir
genauso auch vieles geopfert weil wir
haben extra sehr viele afghanen auf die
bars dass wir nicht so viel draußen und
sie war auch nicht und ja ich will
ja das war nicht selbstverständlich und
wie wir gesehen haben die gerichte
postive getätigt werden disqualifiziert
nicht
ausgeschlossen ja und das war
also auf jeden fall seien ein großes
team auch in der familie
auch wenn sie
nicht am ende kann weil eben nur zwei
stimmen kann aber sie ist auch im einzel
erfolgreich und trainieren gemeinsam
jetzt die war die umstellung damals für
euch als ihr da als drei junge damen
nach österreich kommt und plötzlich in
einem anderen land oder sport hat aber
weiterhin ausüben wollte war das für
mich waren die eindrücke wie es euch
damals gegangen ja das selbst ja
eigentlich schön wir waren neugierig wie
das lebensbereichen auch das internat
das gibt es so was gibt es in
griechenland mit ja es war okay aber das
zweite jahr war ganz ganz lügen will
kommt ganze zeit geweint wie unser weg
war 100 glaube ich haben wir nicht und
wir haben auf die staatsbürgerschaft
gewartet weil wir dürfen nicht starten
nicht einmal mit dem verein weil ich
gesagt nein gesagt
das waren das dass man nun trainiert und
auch in das haben wir wenig weil wir
haben kein deutsch geredet die lehrer
deutsch grelles ja zumeist ministerinnen
im
französisch sogar dafür ein solches
geredet auf deutsch übersetzt dann
mussten wir das ganze auf kriegs
übersetzt und der musiker verstehen was
sagt und dann anfängt ist damit wir
sagen
ja das war so schwierig aber ja wie wir
dann die staatsbürgerschaft bekommen
haben in 2014 ein monat wurde von der
fifa weltmeisterschaft im jahr liegen ja
jugend ja dann haben wir alles vergessen
ja ein surfer ja das leben begonnen
was hat dich in diesen momenten in
diesen schwierigen momenten wie das
jetzt beschrieben hast das war sicher
nicht einfach für euch drei nicht was
hat sich da geholfen dass wir da
durch geht es natürlich diese situation
ja die familie ja ja es war gut dass wir
zu tief waren nicht alleine
und ich hoffe dass wir irgendwann bist
als dieser begann
ja auch vieles hat ja es war also
schwierig welche rolle spielt oder
mutter in ordnung team meiner karriere
in ordnung erfolgen naja es ist der
künstlerin ja weil ohne sie hätten wir
gar nicht getraut
und zwar sehr jung ja das war eine sehr
große sieht ja sie hat sofort an diese
idee sozusagen geglaubt ja und sie hat
zum beispiel mal gesagt weil ich vor der
matura haben wir uns gesagt ja die
leider auch angesagt ja vielleicht
konnte er die klasse wiederholen da wir
ja nicht alles war einfach ein vorschlag
einfach so
negativ war sondern damit wir uns ein
bisschen nicht so viel stress machen
auch weil wir die jüngste spielen hat im
jahr 2016 und die wahrheit gesagt nein
nein das ich bin mir sicher er sagt da
ist und er haben es geschafft
sie hat ihm an uns geglaubt egal
ein wichtiger grundstein zu wie du
jetzt habe ich vorher angefangen über
die europa meisterschaft zu reden und
dann sind wir auch auf andere tage
kommen es war die lang ersehnte und lang
erkämpfte erste große medaille bei einem
großereignis für euch
europameisterschaft und auch im vorfeld
war das ihr habt wahrscheinlich damit
gerechnet gehabt das war aber auch vom
feedback von der nationen im was ich so
mitbekommen habe auf den sozialen medien
es irgendwie endlich endlich haben sie
das bekommen wofür sie hart gearbeitet
haben wie ist es euch damals gegangenen
europameisterschaft so knapp vor den
olympischen spielen als ihr das
geschafft habe und die bronzemedaille
gewonnen ja das war eigentlich eine sehr
sehr große bestätigung
von yahoo
arbeit wir haben auch nicht gewusst wenn
du solche dabei das not nidda und dann
glaubst du ja vielleicht bin ich nicht
gut oder vielleicht keine ahnung war es
ja du bist nicht sicher aber das hat mir
sicherheit gegeben
und ja es ist auch das erste mal nach so
vielen jahren das
auch wer also hat das heißt man ja ja
nicht auch wenn ich das material
ja und ja nächstes jahr haben wir haben
wir wieder die europameisterschaft und
wir hoffen dass wir das wiederholen
das tier gehört sie in dem sind jetzt
dadurch dass ein grundstück von der art
und weise wie es bewertet wird in dem
sinne wenn man die teams kennt der weiß
was sie für formen zu haben werden dass
man das auch schon ungefähr einschätzen
kann wer zu den medien und werten gehört
also kann man euch für die zukunft immer
zu den medaillenkandidaten bei
großereignissen zählen die ja und das
ist auch ein ziel für uns dass wir mehr
wissen nicht fahren in paris oder in
lausanne service aber dass wir
irgendwann ist es vielen daher auch
weltmeister ja jetzt wollen wir das
wirklich offiziell sagen weil
normalerweise sagen wir sogar vor
diesen spielen haben sie haben uns viele
leute gefragt ja was da jetzt ja wir
haben gesagt ob zuerst finale aber dass
er selbstverständlich und dann taucht
obwohl wir eigentlich gewusst haben dass
wir auch
ja ich hoffe
aber dass jetzt wollen wir das wirklich
sagen dass sie das wäre eine medaille so
welt premiere gehabt sich angekündigt
paris oder in los angeles macht ihr eine
medaille wir hatten vorher schon gesagt
wo ich hab gefragt was man denn dafür
braucht das würde es dann brauchen damit
ihr in paris oder in los angeles
wirklich eine medaille erringen und
bleibt also was kann man sich vorstellen
muss dafür noch alles passieren ist sich
sicher
dass wir sie überzeugen dass wir gut
sind dass wir zu der erste group eckhard
ganze sogar jetzt zum beispiel bei den
jüngsten spielen haben sie können uns
viele leute gesagt dass wir in die top
vier oder sogar mit einem eilig
verdienen okay soweit denke mir jetzt
nicht weil wir sind ja siebte aber das
ja da sagen milch
sicherheiten wie das finanziert und sehr
sehr und ja es freut uns einfach dass
viele leute glauben dass wir
ja und ihr seid ja auch aufgefallen ein
bisschen im doppel mit einer fotografie
mit dem programm ich habe die musik
dauern die moral weil ich natürlich hat
eineinhalb jahre gehabt aber eine teure
aber jetzt da auch etwas getraut etwas
ungewöhnlicher das zu machen ein
bisschen gruseliger der musik ein
bisschen actionreicher war das auch
bewusst dass er da ein bisschen ein
zeichen setzen wollte ja weil wir im
synchronschwimmen ist immer so klasse
musik schwanensee weniger haben wir
gemacht und jetzt wollten wir irgendwas
ganz anders machen einen anderen stil
sie hat mehr aggressiv wenn das kann von
uns noch nicht gesehen auch nicht
erwartet ja und ein vorteil für uns ist
eigentlich dass wir alles wie man gar
nicht mein alle musikstile alles viele
ja nicht nur glas ist der musiker nun
aggressiver musik sondern fast alles ja
das hat den leuten sehr gut gefahren
dann werde sich der trainer sogar auch
deshalb wirklich dass selbst klar dass
wir
so wirklich dass ihr zufrieden waren
nach dem wettkampf das ist ein gutes
zeichen und lässt auch für die zukunft
gut laufen fallen diese vielseitigkeit
die angesprochen haben dass die
anscheinend auch wichtig ist bei den
bewertungen ich glaube trotzdem dass es
momente kommen oder momente kommen
können wo wohl wieder das gefühl habe
dass ungefähr da hätten wir uns mehr
verdient ihr hat jetzt auch jetzt in
tokio den ersten startplatz beim ersten
schwimmen und das ja auch so eine
situation die unangenehm sein kann
wir haben gesagt am anfang des jahres
ist wenn wir irgendwann mal
eins haben dann bitte nicht versäumen
spiel weil alle wissen dass ein bisschen
glaube ich man das sogar das gegenteil
getan das beeinflusst die werden sich da
und wie wir dann das ganze feld haben
das wäre nicht nur allein sind sogar
eine welt
gewertet
und sie haben es gesagt ja super ich
freue mich auf mich weil ich arbeite bei
der kanzlerin gesehen ist super aber
sage das
grab das ist so wirklich ich wünsche
euch wirklich viel glück dabei
eine welt gesichtern sagt das zeige ich
ganz schlecht
bekommen was eigentlich ein neues system
übernächstes jahr und ich hoffe dass sie
das auch ändern weil es ja sehr schade
dass das ergebnis vom 2
also von der startnummer erste bewertung
dann von den vielleicht ein bisschen
vorsichtiger ist von den werden sagt er
sind auch menschen sie sind auch nicht
so gut vielleicht vorbereitet und nun
darf gewöhnt auf die banken
aber wenn russland zum beispiel ist
das bild das bild keine lawinen die in
die sie war das tagen war einst aber für
alle anteile als land das spielt das
eine rolle und das hängt dann mit dem
zusammen was er vorher schon gesagt hat
es mit dem standing aber auf jeden fall
ob neues system oder nicht ihr habt euch
auf jeden fall ein standing erschwommen
dass ich sicher für die nächsten jahr
viel erfolg garantieren wird ich wünsche
euch natürlich viel erfolg ich freue
mich schon auf eure nächste choreografie
damit bisher auch das einfallen lassen
wenn du wirklich werde unter wasser mit
euch und euren schon
auf jeden fall alles gute und danken
auch dass hier wieder mit dabei war es
beim sport bot bis zum nächsten mal
servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]